[Musique]
ambiance décontractée pour cette master
class autour du beatbox quentin
s'applique faire de la musique en
imitant des instruments uniquement avec
sa bouche
un art qu'il attire depuis un moment
j'apprends de nouveaux trucs corps bah
moi je fais du beatbox depuis quelques
années déjà des pipes du coup l'harmonie
de tous les sons ça permet de faire des
choses vraiment cool et ça fait libérer
sa créativité et le participant a eu
l'honneur d'échanger avec heroes un
jeune beatboxer saint pierrois
c'est un très bon élève déjà il sait
déjà utilisé à la machine donc c'est
super donc on peut approfondir un peu
les notions que je peux aborder et
surtout on peut faire des choses
ensemble
la danse était aussi au programme du
festival place aux battles qui ont réuni
de nombreux danseurs des danseurs qui
ont appris de nouveaux styles de danse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai jamais fait du hip hop ou répétées
du classique du thelle du tambora et
ballades danse avec casey ctic et voilà
enfin
au début j'étais un peu perplexe a
séduit jamais fait une époque mais
l'objectif faire découvrir aussi au
public les différents aspects de ces
danses justin eva sont émerveillés
on voit de tout de tout des filles les
garçons ils ont vraiment un nouveau
super s'enchaînent et on voit cette
année les filles même si la
programmation a été privé de beaucoup
d'artistes internationaux
les amateurs d'art urbain ont répondu
présent à ce grand rendez vous culturel
[Applaudissements]